I went through such a trial by fire on
my very first thing Wet Hot American
Summer where it poured rain every single
day almost every day when you're filming
that right daylight exterior short low
budget shoot it's supposed to be a nice
day it all takes place in one sunny day
and it's pouring pouring rain all day
and so it was the ultimate daily like
what the are we gonna do situation
and I learned then it's like to let go
of what's out of your control focus on
what you what Solutions might be in
front of you and just do it and and
somehow on set with that structure I
thrive you know where you don't have to
think about what am I going to do today
you know what you've got you've got to
get up and do